[Musique]
c'est avec la loi defferre de 1982 dit
de décentralisation que les régions
politique en france ont vu leurs
compétences élargies mais comment a t'on
perçu cette journée est le rôle
politique de la région écoutant le point
de vue du maire d'une des plus petites
communes d'aquitaine situé dans les
montagnes béarnaises qui a participé à
cette journée
pour nom d'avoir c'est un petit peu une
capitale qui est en train de naître de
par la loi la capitale de la région
aquitaine bordeaux qui se dote
aujourd'hui d'un siège nous bien entendu
le lustre la richesse pour nous elles se
situent surtout en termes de subsistance
donc nous attendons effectivement
beaucoup de la région et qu'elle soit un
guide qu'elle soit
une instance qui lance les programmes et
qui nous aident à maintenir la vie dans
notre montagne dans nos villages nous
ainsi concernant la vallée d'aspe la
région ont apporté notamment avec les
contrats le contrat de pays le premier
contrat de pays et puis de contrats que
nous venons de signer maintenant un
contrat de revitalisation et un
contraste à sion valais qui ont été
impulsés directement par la région au
camp qu'il est un peu trop tôt pour
répondre à cette question mais je crois
que tu es fondamentalement si on arrive
à le faire fonctionner la région a une
place à trouver car un département est
probablement trop modeste
territorialement mais une région peut
arriver à tenir un flambeau et à devenir
un porte-drapeau à condition de lui
trouver une cohérence et à condition de
les trouver j'allais dire presque un
idéal
[Musique]